on an intensely complex issue ensuring
the victim's voices are heard
I've been deeply moved by the
testimonies outlined in the latest
report
and the victim's bravery and coming
forward should not be overlooked
the issuing of the second interim report
specifically on compensation was not
anticipated by the government until
we're informed by the inquiry in
February this year however we very much
appreciate and welcome sir Brian taking
this approach
the government is considering intensely
the recommendations outlined in this
report and work is underway at PACE
across all relevant departments to
respond fully
my right honorable friend the member for
maidenhead announced the infected blood
inquiry in 2017.
to examine the circumstances that led to
individuals being given contaminated
blood and blood products in the UK
the inquiry chaired by Brian langstaff
commenced on the 2nd of July 2018. I'd
like to reiterate our total endorsement
for my right honorable friends point
that the contaminated blood Scandal of
the 70s and 80s should simply never have
happened
in tandem with the ongoing inquiry my
right honorable friend the member for
Portsmouth North as the then pay Master
General commissioner Robert Francis
Casey to produce a compensation
framework study in anticipation of a
recommendation from the inquiry to set
up a compensation scheme
the findings of this study were
published in June 2022
shortly after this so Brian published
his first interim report of the affected
blood inquiry in July 2022 in his report
so Brian recommended that the government
make interim payments to infected
individuals and their bereaved partners
the government accepted this
recommendation in full on the 17th of
August 2022 an interim compensation
payments of a hundred thousand pounds
have been paid to those infected
individuals and their bereaved Partners
registered with existing support schemes
as I said to the house in December we
have much to do and I wish to assure the
house that this is a priority for the
government and we will continue to
progress it those are my words in
December and I would like to assure the
house that this commitment absolutely
remains
so Brian's most recent report sets out
what the inquiry recommends as an
appropriate means of compensating both
those infected and affected and the
mechanism for delivering that
compensation
in doing so it sets out the complexity
of what is a multi-layered issue
the recommendations in his report
outline that those infected and affected
should be granted legal support and
infected and affected people and the
Estates of infected people should be
able to claim for categories of loss
against five Awards
injury impact award social impact award
autonomy award care award and financial
loss award
this is rather than claiming on
individual assessment of each
application
in addition those dissatisfied with
their compensation payments should have
redressed through an appeal to a
structure outside of the compensation
scheme
the report has also proposed mechanisms
so Brian thinks would ensure the
fairness of the compensation scheme he
is recommended that a scheme is
administered by an arms length Body
chaired by a high high court judge or
equivalent and advised by legal and
medical professionals as well as the
beneficiaries of the scheme
in addition to this sir Brian has
proposed that the route through the
courts should still remain open to
beneficiaries
so Brian has agreed with much as a
Robert study that there are also
differences in approach
for example Sir Robert outlined in his
study that the scheme should be
delivered locally in each of the four
nations as this was the preference of
the victims
so Brian has recommended that the scheme
is delivered by a central body whilst
continuing the support provided by the
the existing infected blood support
schemes which should be continued and
guaranteed for life
by legislation or secure government
undertaking
there is also Divergence in the
consideration of scope of those eligible
for compensation payments including the
extension of payments to those with
hepatitis B and not providing payments
to the Estates of those affected
so Brian's interim report is detailed
and it's only right that the government
will need to consider the complexities
they set out thoroughly when preparing
our response
the house will recognize that health is
a devolved matter and I'll be discussing
the report with my colleagues in the
devolved Administrations
as I said at the start of my statement
the government welcomes the publication
of the infected blood inquiries second
interim report to assist its ongoing
work however we do not underestimate the
complexity that these recommendations
which do need careful consideration for
example so Brian recommends that an
arm's length body in which his Majesty's
government would have no ongoing role
Beyond providing taxpayer funds as
required by the body or anything like
this scale this would be a new departure
and does have implications for
accountability of government which will
lead careful consideration alongside how
its financial implications will be
managed
I would however like to reassure the
house that while the government is
progressing work to ensure that we are
in the best possible position to respond
fully at the end of the inquiry every
recommendation by Sir Brian including in
relation to timing and a further interim
payment is receiving intense Focus
my colleagues in the department for
Health and Social care are aware of the
issues that Brian has raised in relation
to psychological support
under the current psychological support
scheme for England there is provision
for a grant of up to 900 pounds a year
for established beneficiaries and family
members for counseling and talking
therapy the department for Health and
Social care is undertaking research to
look at the psychological support needs
that so the decisions on commissioning
of the spoke service are based on robust
evidence and meet the requirement
in closing I would like to reiterate the
need for Pace people die
every week as a result of the impact of
the Scandal
this government wants to deliver
resolution and we are working at PACE
across all relevant departments to
consider the recommendations as outlined
in this latest report and to ensure we
are best replaced to respond to the
inquiries final report I commend this
statement to the house